- one what's up everyone welcome to
simulation series I'm your host Alan
soccent and thanks for tuning in today
we have the pleasure of sitting down
with Ricardo Baca what's up what is up
allan good man to see you all the way
from Denver I know right popped in to
San Francisco for a couple days it's
good to be here yes it's really good to
have you thanks for texting me I'm just
being like yo I'm coming into the city
that's in the vodcasts and I'm like
alright let's do it this is a
back-to-back you guys saw the Alex
Koppel yonghwan on biotechnology now
we're gonna be diving into cannabis when
we talking about the wellness the
medicine and the spiritual insight of
cannabis and then we'll run through all
of the cool simulation questions we have
ready for Ricardo as well Ricardo's
backgrounds awesome I call him the
leading cannabis journalist in the
United States
he just started my grasslands but before
that you were with the Denver Post as a
Marijuana editor still with the cannabis
there's a founder and now my grasslands
maybe you want to tell us a bit about
the content agency and yeah exactly what
about that yeah you know I'm a lifelong
journalist and that's all I ever knew
and so back in late 2013 when my boss
asked me if I wanted to if I was
interested in being the newspapers
full-time cannabis editor I was
definitely into it and it presented a
multitude of opportunities and basically
over the course the next 3-4 years we
brought cannabis journalism into the now
you know beyond the propaganda and the
misinformation of the 70s 80s and 90s
and even today yeah and also not the
activism oriented high times generated
you know kind of advocate journalism so
we've kind of did that and I left that
gig about a year ago because you know
daily newspapers are struggling and I
started my own agency and we're very
much a journalism minded agency and
we're working to help spread the good
work that's being done in cannabis and
and other industries so that's where
we're at and we having a blast good and
is that a lot of other companies asking
you guys to help them better voice what
they're doing into the world exactly yes
so I'm still producing journalism I
still write for the Denver Post I still
write for The Daily Beast and for
Esquire but right now the bulk of my
work very much is agency work so we're
doing PR marketing social digital and a
lot of thought leadership we're helping
these executives really have their
vision seen and and and published in top
outlets I think that's important for
thought leaders in this new industry is
it's just taking off especially here in
California to to be heard and and to be
seen and and that's what we can help
them do yeah that's awesome I'm really
happy that you ended up starting
grasslands that's this your your own
beast your own agency out in the world
and I think you're gonna end up being
kind of the the beacon for the
industries like you said your thought
leadership focused that's so crucial for
this industry moving forward maybe let's
let's walk down some of those big sort
of thought leadership areas of expertise
that you have and that you're bringing
to the industry why they're important
absolutely you know I think every
industry every space and sector has its
thought leaders the people who are
really guiding that conversation moving
it forward and we're coming at this from
a unique perspective in that we've been
the journalists covering this at the top
outlets and and capital Jade journalism
you know we're not on this side or the
other really straight down the middle
and we've been covering these issues as
they've been coming up because when you
think about it this has been an
unregulated substance for for almost the
entirety of its history we're talking
black market and then California is the
first to legalize medicinal
but even when that happened California
has never had a regulated cannabis
industry until the last couple months
and in fact California's medical
industry is still completely unregulated
it is regulating recreational right now
when you think about that awkward space
of government introduction in
introducing regulations to a space that
existed in the black market as recently
as five years ago it's very complicated
so some of these thought leadership
avenues that we're talking about are
responsible cultivation practices how do
you grow this plant responsibly
sustainably without using the the
chemicals that are banned for its
production chemicals that you don't want
to be inhaling especially after you let
your lighting a fire to them we're
talking about you know is it not only
pesticide use but but actual lab testing
protocols and you know in Colorado I
call it the big four years they're
supposed to test for potency and for
residual solvents mmm for contaminants
and for pesticides Wow and so you know
to make sure that we're doing this right
as journalists we help the industry
accountable and we also help regulars
like regulators accountable as well it's
important to make sure that a state
agency or a city agency is treating the
industry fairly and and now we're just
really helping not the regulators but
the industry be accountable and be
beacons of responsibility and and not
only do it right but make sure that the
world knows that they're doing it right
because that's important you know you
have a lot of choices when you go
shopping and if you know that this one
company has outstanding growing
principles and you know that this other
company has a pretty amazing corporate
social responsibility campaign that
inevitably impacts your buying decisions
and so that's what we're out there is to
hopefully guide those buying decisions
is so OnPoint so good everything from
the corporate social responsibility side
to actually being able to produce the
plant sustainably and those four tasks
those are so important pesticides
yeah I'm residual solvent yeah
in many cases they're using solvents to
extract cannabinoids and the terpenes
from the plant matter and you don't want
to leave that beaut beaut ain't in there
that's not good for us yes
and so residual solvent pesticide what
were the other two again contaminants
and so that like mildew powdery mildew
and mold or yeah and then the other is
potency you know and when you're buying
it's very important for edibles you know
you're buying something that says this
is 2.5 milligrams of activated THC in
this edible or 10 you know you just want
to make sure that that is indeed two
point five or ten that you can have a
repeatable experience yeah you know and
you're not going brand to brand and
having wildly different experiences so
you know it's necessary and it's also
amazingly awkward and right now you guys
are going through a really painful time
in California because you introduced
regulations to an industry that's that's
of course it decades-old in terms of the
legal market but but many many more
decades old when you're contemplating
the early illegal market especially up
in the Emerald triangle and now you're
introducing these kinds of standards to
it and it's uncomfortable and and many
in the industry in fact many people
believe most and the industry will
ultimately fail while a select few will
triumph and and learn to abide by these
very strict regulations and deliver a
respectable legitimate product to
consumers which is the one of the main
cases for a regulated market the seems
to be the consistent trend with
organizations that kind of get birthed
into the world is that the ones that you
know abide by regulation principles that
have at codes of ethics especially in
this new millennial and Gen Z generation
coming up they're looking for companies
that have corporate social
responsibility or sustainability within
their code of ethics I'm to fund those
companies with their money to buy from
them the ones that are very careful with
their potency and with their amount the
leftover solvents that are in it
pesticides etc that's this is all very
very crucial okay so now explain to us
what the hell's going on because you
just said that within California the
the right the we're regulating the the
recreational aspect of it but the
medicinal still not regulated
yeah and in Colorado where do you guys
sit both are being regulated sure yeah
yeah you know it's it's this crazy tough
history because we have the Controlled
Substances Act right or cannabis is
remains a Schedule one substance
alongside cocaine heroin actually I
don't even think cocaine cocaine might
be scheduled to and cannabis is
considered to be more dangerous and more
deadly because of course right not by
the Medical Journal this was an
interesting one that I learned I think
like six years ago or even longer goes
at the UK Medical Journal ranks cannabis
is actually into LSD ask some of the
lowest in terms of the chemical
dependency as well as the impact on the
health and of the body actually tobacco
and alcohol are way up there as well as
cocaine heroine is that word yes yeah
and and that's the beauty of science
right because if we can just have a
science-based conversation like the
physicians like these top-rated medical
journals including in this country JAMA
the Journal of the American Medical
Association and the New England Journal
of Medicine where they're having
science-based conversations about
cannabis you know as opposed to the
federal government which is ignoring the
science and adhering to this 1970s era
concept of the war on drugs of marijuana
being as dangerous and addictive and
deadly as heroin but you know so we
because of the Controlled Substances Act
we have this patchwork of marijuana laws
some outright prohibition some CBD only
some expansive medical and some
recreational you know Colorado was the
the first to regulate its medical system
we had regulators and and people in the
legislature who realized and recognized
the value
of a government-controlled market saying
this isn't going anywhere
in fact it's only probably going to grow
when they were right yeah so we were the
first to do that and we were also the
first to implement a legal regulated
recreational market where you where
California is you guys are right now
implementing this legal regulate
regulated rec market and on the medical
side you're still working on it and it's
a decade's old medical market it's the
oldest in the country and it's it's a
lot of work and these regulators are
already overworked on the REC side so
eventually you guys will have
regulations on both sides and it's going
to be uncomfortable it's going to be
awkward yes but I really think it's the
right move for California and why don't
you walk us down some of the regulations
that Colorado has put together for the
medical and the recreational industry
and how those are ending up flourishing
now or what's kind of what are you
learning along the way
you know we have these regulations that
have been put into into the into the
bylaws by the by the state but then we
also have some federal level
recommendations that have been made but
it's been in the news a lot lately in
the last month those particular
memorandums were just recently rescinded
so now these state markets are kind of
operating and avoid so for example
Colorado we do have mandatory laboratory
testing for the big four that we were
talking about earlier right every one
that grows has to go through the
mandatory laboratory testing eventually
they will it's written into the rules
and regs that they do but it doesn't say
so you think that's part of the future
for sure the evidence in both cannabis
grower has to go through the big four
tests without a doubt that's awesome we
know yeah we know that's in the future
of this so to see how we treat the
alcohol this is how we treat tobacco
that's grown is you know the American
South and and but one of the one of the
reasons that this industry has really
thrived in the recreational era is
because under President Obama
a sistent Attorney General James Cole
one of Eric Holder's assistants he wrote
the Cole memo which is arguably the most
important piece of you know guidance
from the federal government ever
regarding cannabis and basically it said
if you pay attention to these seven or
eight things we will leave your state
programs alone and those things war you
know keep it out of children's hands
yeah let's make sure it's not crossing
state borders you know and of course
California can't control what happens to
that edible or that ate the flower once
it's purchased from a legal retailer but
these are the these are the rules that
were laid out by the Obama Justice
Department and there were very very
realistic rules because that was
basically them saying we don't know what
to do would just be as responsible as
possible and now we're in a world where
last month our current Attorney General
Jeff Sessions rescinded the Cole memo
and all the other cannabis related
memorandums and so these state legal
businesses are operating in California
Colorado Massachusetts coast-to-coast
without any federal guidance whatsoever
and it certainly amped up the anxiety
and the industry because it's it's no
protection it's it's it's no federal
guidance and now they really are
operating completely on their own yeah
there's got to be some sort of federal
guidance and the principles that were
put in by the Cole memo sought to be
very understandable totally so what is
the age right now in Colorado is at
eighteen or twenty-one it's 21 20th it's
21 throughout the u.s. in every state
where it's medicinally it's 21 well
Medical is 18 in certain states but
recreational is 21 just like alcohol
yeah but what's interesting is our
neighbors to the north of course I mean
the second biggest story to California
is Canada there they're about to become
the second country to ever federally
legalize recreational E the first being
Uruguay but now Canada is doing it and
they have a similar state model only
province by province are setting out the
guidelines under which it will be sold
and so some of these provinces are
saying sure if you're 18 or older you
can purchase recreational cannabis and
other provinces are saying we
you need to be 21 so it's a conversation
that's happening up there yeah and
that's federal guidance and that's a
really crucial principle in the
conversation and you know many people
argue that oh I can vote and I can go
serve in the military at 18 why not be
able to purchase marijuana exactly so
and we don't know exactly the
neurological effects toward the full
extent again this is where we need a lot
of scientific testing longitudinal
studies to figure out if it's okay for a
teen or if it's better for 21 to kind of
figure that out yeah we do generally
know like the no substance is good for
the developing brain there's a different
you know they're they're different ideas
of what when the brain is developed is
it developed at 18 at 21 or 25 yeah
generally you know we don't know and and
and the lack of research right now is
really one of the most frustrating areas
and this but we're coming out of this
Dark Age of prohibition right and and
even though we're taking our time coming
out of this Dark Age finally we're
starting to see a CDC
and a DEA and an FDA that are more open
to researching this substance not only
for its potential dangers of which there
certainly are some but more importantly
for its medical efficacy and this is
this is huge we need to understand that
we need to understand its impact on the
developing brain on the adult brain yeah
and and right yeah you know and until
then we're just kind of our own guinea
pigs but if we if we look at these other
Heino and if we look but if we look at
how we learned about alcohol and tobacco
and we talk about these mass studies
that were peer-reviewed and and double
blind and placebo controlled back in the
day that really involved tens of
thousands of subjects that's why we know
what we know about alcohol and tobacco
and their impact on the human body their
impact on communities and we do not have
that equivalent study for cannabis right
now and who knows it's probably going to
be a decade plus before we do have that
kind of
data yeah and you listed it all there
that's a really good summary of exactly
what we need to do in kind of the next
decade to better understand the effects
for adults for kids and also to get deep
into the science scientific efficacy for
bird disease for for health for
medicinal purposes maybe we dive into
that for a little bit as well
so what happens some of these like big
actually constants from conscious
therapeutics as a patron of very cool
yeah oak stimulation so that right were
constants yeah yeah they do great work
so walk us down some of the yeah the
medicinal and the wellness benefits of
using cannabis what are the most cool
ones so you know we were talking about
top-level medical journals and
especially in my journalism I I like to
rely on the most you know the most
legitimate research available and so a
couple years ago I believe it was 2015
the Journal of the American Medical
Association commonly known as JAMA came
out with a giant analysis where they
analyzed every legitimate study of
cannabis to see what is there truly
proof for because what they were looking
at and this patchwork of state state
laws was okay here you have PTSD and
chronic pain and here you have cancer
and MS and here you have epilepsy and
really what do we know that cannabis is
good for from a medical professional
medical position and through that
massive analysis which was
groundbreaking and huge they really
determined that cannabis we know
cannabis is legitimate medicine for four
conditions one is spasticity involving
MS it's it's huge in terms of how much
that this helps people suffering from an
MS one is chronic and neuropathic pain
yeah
funny because it's chronic pain also not
funny because chronic pain oh my god
chronic pain suffers I can't even
imagine I have a couple of friends in my
life who one of them is sometimes up
awake for days on end because she can't
sleep addiction to opioids yeah of
course
of course and then others are involving
nausea that's surrounded by you know
chemotherapy cancer treatments wasting
disease you know it sounds like a joke
when we talk about munchies but really
it's it's one of the medical phenomena
of cannabis because if you are wasting
because and you're just shedding weight
and you can't keep it on and you're
going through cancer treatments you know
you will have top-rated doctors tell you
have you tried weed have you tried these
edibles it's going to make you want to
eat and it makes believers out of people
yeah and it's all around this construct
of the munchies which is kind of amazing
so I mean you have the brightest minds
in medicine now saying missus medicine
and that's huge it's such a huge shift
from even you know you think about when
Colorado and Washington first
implemented these legal sales back in
2014 we live in a different social
dynamic now where where where physicians
are writing books and and of course
research papers about marijuana as
medicine and and that's that's just so
encouraging and you mentioned opioids
and and there's a developing body of
work there that's really truly exciting
because of course our country's going
through a massive devastating opioid
epidemic you know some states are
getting hurt worse than others hit worse
than others and it's an it's just awful
because you know this industry is
powerful and doctors are prescribing
them at record rates and they're trying
to pull back but now they're they've
created this they've they've helped
create this epidemic and now we have
hundreds of thousands of people who are
addicted to these absolutely deadly
drugs
and there is a feeling in the medical
cannabis community that this might be an
exit drug which would be so ironic
because of course it's been the gateway
drug for decades and we've been taught
to be to fear it as a gateway drug
that's going to bring us into more
dangerous what happens though as
scientific research is starting to point
out now if it's actually an exit drug
from something that's considerably more
deadly like opioids and and going back
to that JAMA study chronic pain that's
why so many people are prescribed
opioids in the first place and and we do
not know scientifically if this is legit
exit but there are three legit studies
that are just early pieces forming a
foundation that show states with access
to some form of cannabis whether it's
medical or recreational they have fewer
opioid-related overdoses they have fewer
opioid related ER admissions and they
have less Medicare spending on opioids
so I mean that's the reset have been
done in American universities Wow and
that's pretty compelling
yeah and it's too early to say but if
the Journal of the American Medical
Association is saying yeah it does help
with chronic pain and then these early
early studies are saying yeah it we
think that it has an impact on these
factors too I think we're building up
into a pretty monumental discovery
because if some piece of literature
comes out in the next year or two that
says definitively you people who are
addicted to opioids can use this to get
away from that you know and that's not
to say that weed is not addictive
because it is not to say that it's not
potentially dangerous because it is just
significantly less dangerous than
opioids than alcohol than nicotine
these are the things we know about it as
medicine awesome yeah
is a great journey down at all thank you
it's exciting but then you mentioned
wellness and you know one of my clients
and friends is a guy named Steve
DeAngelo and he actually sells cannabis
from a shop not far from here in Oakland
and and if you read his book the
cannabis manifesto he he talks about how
wellness is is is very different than
medicine and and really like even if
you're not using cannabis medicinally
inevitably you're using it for wellness
regardless of the purpose of the journey
or the purpose of the experience you're
seeking and so I happen to agree with
that I think it has a multitude of
wellness properties I was just writing a
column on the plane here yesterday about
an adjacent area because it's just
uncanny how this improves your life in
different realms and I think for me I
can tie all of those back to my own
personal and individual wellness
okay medicine and wellness this is
awesome let's unpack a couple of the
things and let's go into wellness the
come very intertwined okay so on them on
the medicine side of things huge first
best spasticity huge for chronic pain
huge for cancer patients being able to
consume food increasing their hunger and
their appetite huge for decreasing
medical cost getting off of opioids this
is all so crucial being an exit trunk
was the first time that that was
communicated to the public really well
saternus that really needs to get
communicated the public really well
being like no it's actually in many
cases going to be an exit drug so let's
um let's let's get let's get talking
about that okay um that's this is all
amazing it was really well described all
of the different medicinal benefits
where do we stand on specific strains
or cannabinoid specific antibodies and
strange impacting the specific medicinal
cases that you are describing so is
there a different one for spasticity and
different one for chronic pain etc you
know I think we operate in this
construct of strains and indica and
sativa now because it's what our
knowledge is and it's our relationship
with the plant especially as we emerge
from the black market but I think
inevitably the future involves us
getting away from strains and thinking
about cannabis to in a different way
because it's not about this strain it's
not about how nature made it which is
something that's semi controversial to
say and we'll make some weed nerds you
know certainly grumpy it's about how we
engineer it to impact those certain
ailments it is I mean it's it's all
about that ratio of cannabinoids to
terpenes to other things that are
present in this full plow in the full
flower and so how can we do that well I
mean you know through modern extraction
technology we can already extract and
separate cannabinoids and terpenoids or
concentrates and that's what you're
seeing exactly that's already happening
not widespread but certainly it's
happening you literally get prescribed
the cannabis oil that gives you that you
can consume for purposes of spasticity
that it will be branded that way mm-hmm
and in many ways you know I mean think
about how the pharmaceutical industry
has co-opted so many of these master
plants or these you know natural
substances inevitably we're looking at a
future where this is happening and right
now a British company called GW
pharmaceutical is pushing a
antiepileptic drug through the FDA
process and they will probably be
successful and it's called epidural x
and they published their findings and
the Journal of the New England Journal
of Medicine last year and it showed that
I believe it was like 35 or 42 percent
of epilepsy patients
incurred fewer seizures when they were
on this synthetic went on this CBD drug
and that's going to be sold
pharmaceutically probably in the next
year and so yeah what you're talking
about a specific ratio being subscribed
to MS patients it's not really happening
right now but it's definitely the future
and where we're going because it's not
about green crack or lemon skunk or Sour
Diesel it really is more about a 3 to 1
to 1 ratio of CBD the THC to CBG and and
whatever that ends up looking with a
terpene profile that is also modifying
that that chemical equation somehow I
get I think I'm talking a little bit out
of my league here but I am confident
that that's the future we're moving
toward yeah that's the person again
that's a huge part of personalized
medicine in general personalized to
specific ailments as well as potentially
personalized to the person and what they
desire out of the wellness purposes
let's say so yeah let's let's dive into
some of the wellness purposes and just
writing a little bit about it on the
plane tell us a bit about that so I mean
you know this is very anecdotal but but
personally I've never I've never felt
the effects of legitimate severe anxiety
but I certainly have acute anxiety that
that pops its head up every once in a
while and you know that sometimes those
situations you're prepared and sometimes
you're not but more and more especially
in a legal recreational state like
California or Colorado you can be
prepared and so I was on a plane
yesterday and I don't generally like
being on airplanes because there's just
a lot to to kind of get past especially
when my acute anxiety kind of kicks in
and whether it's the kid kicking that
your chair and behind you or the the
screaming baby or whatever it might be
you know now walking into a plane
already lifted because you had that
edible right before going through
security
it's it's amazing how much it improves
my quality of life in that experience of
being in a 10 can for two and a half
hours on my way here or 16 hours on my
way to Beijing it's it's it's insane how
much that improves my own well-being and
I very much look at that as as a
wellness use but yes but it's
productivity you know on the Saturday is
where I just know that I need to crush
eight hours of yard work before I can
even start thinking about what I'm doing
that night you know wake wake up with
nice 15 20 milligrams with my breakfast
and and it's on and I am focused and
yard work and laundry and cleaning the
house and doing everything else and I
absolutely look at that as a wellness
attribute as well as it's very much
improving my life and helping me do the
things that I need to accomplish to get
to be able to have fun or to get to San
Francisco or whatever it might be yeah
there's definitely huge benefits for
wellness that are different across
individuals and like you experiencing
acute anxiety versus somebody that
experiences tremendous anxiety when
they're using cannabis maybe they need a
different composition of cannabinoids
for themselves maybe that would be
better but I would like to you know
maybe challenge a bit on the Wellness
side and let's let's let's say that yeah
there are they're good they're people
that can use cannabis that can focus in
and work productively on the things that
they need to get done and it can help
people get past anxiety there is also
people that get induced anxiety they
start thinking they're the center of the
universe and other people are observing
them and they're getting
upset about that anxious and then
there's also the productivity side of
things where it seems as though at times
people can slow down people can get
distracted more easily so there could be
you know different conversations about
the productivity as well for different
people absolutely and I think for me too
it's all I know that there are certain
products that I will be laser-focused
after taking and I also know that there
will you know indica into couch yeah I
have those nights as you've never heard
the intake into couch
that's so party it's true it's a it's
the mnemonic device for yeah that that
weed connoisseurs use but but I think
it's it's important to note here that
it's not for everybody yeah right I mean
and I think alcohol or tobacco yeah yeah
I mean no matter what I'm always a
journalist I always want to spread
quality information so weed is not for
everybody
contrary to what some people think you
know you know some people try it and
it's just not it's not the weight of the
tea it's a great way to put it but it is
a major potential exit drug for so many
different free use of opioids etc we
have so much medicine all purposes there
so to limit the medicinal purposes
because of someone's own wellness
anecdote is probably not one personal
anecdote or even it's not for everyone
so but enable people to use it
medicinally still and even
recreationally for their wealth wellness
purposes alright let's talk about this
because this is what we talked about a
new West Summit and this is actually
really I think probably one of the most
important things that the industry faces
as well but its overall branding and its
overall image there's a big culture kind
of the stoner culture image which is we
smoked up and then we you know we we
contribute to the economy by ordering
pizza and playing video games or
whatever and then there's a
there's the there's this whole other
side of the industry which is the
medicinal benefits the Wellness benefits
how many people it's impacting all this
basically your last twenty minutes
talking about this insanely impactful
and important to communicate how do we
get the like the recreational image and
conversation a little bit more like you
know this is entertaining still cuz it's
funny and it's cute and stuff but also
really highlight this and medicinal than
the Wellness benefits as well so how do
we get those two maybe the branding and
the image to work more together I think
a lot of its just already happening
happening naturally you have people like
me who are branding and marketing minded
content minded individuals who are
working with individual brands and
executives and carefully crafting this
image but when you that the aesthetics
of the industry as a whole and you
definitely have the tie-dye the
backlight you know but I would argue
there's always going to be a place for
that and they don't necessarily need to
change because you know that population
will always exist and they will always
be there and truth be told they were
here a lot a lot longer than I was
they were here way before many people in
the legal market were and so instead of
shunning that aesthetic or that lack of
you know conceptual branding you know
I've always kind of wanted to embrace it
instead because they were they were the
founders of this industry you know of
this you know kit you've northern
Humboldt and and and Trinity and and
Mendo you know the original growers and
that was their aesthetic and and now
you're seeing a much more professional
and polished approach and I think
there's room for both and you will see
the interaction and people dipping into
one way or the other and inevitably this
original this OG pool is is dwindling
and and I think that's okay but you know
you look at High Times Magazine is a
good example 43 years old arguably the
most important brand in can
of us you know and granted they've
changed a lot over the last 43 years and
it looks like more of a traditional
magazine right now more of a traditional
mass-produced mass distributed magazine
but you open those pages you see the ads
you see what they're writing about and
how they're covering it you follow them
on social they have a certain aesthetic
that's very much in tune with that
old-school stoner and that's great but I
started a publication called the
cannabis at the Denver Post and you know
you went there and it looked more like a
professionally designed website we were
not using any puns not intentionally at
least we were approaching it from a
perspective of journalism and not
activism yeah yeah and so we were just
serving this different more modern
consumer and what was interesting in
this whole experiment of media as I was
running cannabis and definitely friends
with my colleagues over at High Times as
well you know eventually we started
having more readers than High Times get
on a monthly basis you know and I think
it was people seeking out legitimate
information vetted information and and
recognizing that this industry was
changing and perhaps the kind of media
they needed to consume was changing too
but at the same time now High Times just
sold last year new owner moved from New
York to LA hiring all new staff and now
what's high time is going to look like a
year from now I think it's going to look
a little bit more like the cannabis than
it is the old school High Times and High
Times will probably still be here in
another forty three years so yeah I
think there's a room on her hand it
keeps popping up The Linde effect and
this scene Talib's sort of been
communicating it through me recently but
the fact that High Times has been around
43 years makes it so the High Times is
more likely to be around forty five more
years
whereas something as new as maybe a
cannabis journal that came out last year
doesn't it probably will only stick
around another year more live more than
likely and it can really easily be
understood by things like maybe the
wheel or the cup that has water it's
gonna be around another six thousand or
whatever years yeah so that's that's an
interesting that you brought it up it's
been coming up so much in life
I would imagine so okay so yeah so you
so High Times is now starting up as a
potentially new more cannabis like
Enterprise a more maybe modern in this
case so there is room for both I agree
there's the room for the professional
medicinal journalism that's stripped of
its bias and activism and stuff like
that and there's room for like the
activism and and the kind of the more
like entertainment the side of things
actually shout out to the Knife media
our friends who strip the bias out of
news go check out the knife Mediacom
they show you where they strip the bias
out of the news it's very interesting
stuff so there's stuff like that that's
emerging in our world so okay so let's
let's talk quick about how what would
what maybe what I'm trying to target in
this conversation which is there's the
medicinal conversations in journalism
there is the kind of like the activism
and entertainment journalism and out of
the entertainment and the activism
journalism there's a decent amount of
people that are kind of doing some
things that are a little bit more not as
productive for maybe 14 year olds to see
and etc and so whether you know whether
it be you know smoking a blunt and then
choosing to do something that isn't
healthy or choosing to you know say
something that is not kind of
counterproductive that's gonna happen
across every industry maybe we don't
need to get into that as much but just
just the idea of when you are
communicating on behalf of like the
entertainment are on behalf of an
industry being aware of who you're
targeting as you're a young audience or
what the media content is that's going
out there because it seems to be really
beneficial to have more people talking
about it from the perspective of the
fact that it's actually having on
people's lives and additionally in terms
of wellness as well but yeah sure get
high order pizza do whatever you want
yeah yeah do your thing as well or write
a you know go mow the lawn after smoking
a J doing or whatever you need
okay so we've chatted about legislation
and chatted about getting the adjourned
which art about the journalism let's
talk about this I mean this is this is a
major major player in the space all of
the entrepreneurship that's going on in
the cannabis industry because red box is
one just go up and order your marijuana
there's so many other ones they're all
players in the game that are like that
now just go right up in order from a box
yeah English intending machines there's
um there's the shipping containers these
are really interesting hydroponic
equipped shipping containers mm-hmm just
freaking order one for a couple ten
thousand bucks get it shipped to your
area of the world and then just start
growing right out of it
there's a lot of entrepreneurship that's
coming out in the space maybe touch on
some of your favorite entrepreneurship
endeavors in the space and why they're
important yeah and there are a lot of
interesting ones you mentioned these
shipping containers that are meant to be
grow boxes basically and those are
fascinating especially as we're watching
the cultivation market and the price of
wholesale cannabis just drop yeah you
know so does it make any sense to buy
this limited modular space when you know
really probably the primary people who
are going to be growing cannabis will be
large-scale cultivators in the next five
years on multiple acres on plot yeah
yeah especially big conversation here of
course home of the small cannabis
farmers and that is the California
Marijuana heritage and I love I think
that's a very interesting model
inevitably tech of course cannabis tech
is at the own market because what we're
finding is a lot of the traditional b2b
resources weren't ready to accommodate
cannabis and maybe in the early days of
legalization they didn't want to work
with these businesses yeah so it needed
a POS or service that was catering and
to its specific and very unique needs
you know and so instead of going with a
traditional offering a multitude of
other businesses have popped up with
great technology solid backends and made
that happen and you have success stories
and you also have some some big moments
of failure and hacks and people's
information getting out and dispensaries
POS machines going down not being able
to make sales so you have that you have
this very consumer focused startup where
it's like a cannabis box you know it's
it's a little bit limited in terms of
what that means in a regulated
environment you know for example
Colorado there's a couple services where
you can subscribe and it's like Birchbox
you know they send you paraphernalia
once a month you know different glass
rolling papers whatever yeah and and
it's somewhat limited because there's no
product in it because it's being mailed
because you can only buy that within a
certain regulated environment being a
dispensary by California one year ago
there was a box you could have signed up
for online paid for it once a month that
it lands at your door through the you
USPS with flower concentrates edibles
and now I don't know that there's room
within the regulatory framework for that
to exist in Colorado but still these
startups without a doubt exist you're
seeing a lot of technological innovation
around what we were talking about
earlier with you know the lab testing
environment and and also the more and
more we become concerned about consuming
a clean product you know you said that
your previous guest was talking about
clean meat yeah and we should absolutely
be concerned about for it you know clean
fruits and vegetables and meats and
cannabis yeah and and and they're
getting that they're getting better at
communicating between this closed-loop
system of you know you grow it
then it's processed if it's being
processed and then the flower and the
edibles and the concentrates are going
into the lab and from the lab into the
store and how can you as a consumer
understand when you pick up that edible
that concentrate that flower exactly
what it tested for in potency residual
solvents pesticides that kind of stuff
because as we've seen this this organic
market grow in our in our grocery stores
especially in this state you know it's
the same thing is about to happen in
cannabis because we should be concerned
about that you know your tomato your
grapes your strawberries you can wash
those before you consume their than just
them and with cannabis you're you're not
only not washing it because you can't
but you're also exposing it to a very
high temperature and inhaling it
directly into your lungs oh my god I
mean it's terrifying and it's it's one
of the reasons why we tested a different
brands of concentrates back in 2015 for
pesticides and ended up finding high
levels of banned illegal chemicals
active ingredient chemicals sure that
you can use on your strawberries but are
very very illegal for use on cannabis
and we published that story on the front
page of the newspaper on a Sunday and it
led to the world's first pest a
marijuana recall and that one recalled
because of the supply chain ended up
leading to the next 20 or 30 recalls Wow
so hey and now better testing moving
forward better lab testing better
testing and you know like defrost yeah
Oregon's Oregon's a great example they
nearly killed their concentrates market
because they amplified their pesticide
regulations they had very stringent
standards and that there could their
their concentrates market struggled to
meet those standards but now they're
meeting those standards and excelling
through those standards and they
probably have the cleanest concentrates
in in the country it's outstanding or
you know how's the cleanest concentrates
in the country just probably they have
the highest standards for pesticide
testing so yeah I wouldn't be surprised
if they do I felt comfortable saying
exactly yeah so those are the better
though the lab and the regulation around
what's what the canvas is going through
the lab the better will be for the
end-user that's actually consuming the
cannabis and using it for the experience
so I mean that's crude so we're talking
about the technology we're talking about
what entrepreneurs are doing it cetera
right and you're got a little bit off
topic I think I think you came right at
it from an interesting perspective which
was that at the at the large scale who
you know we don't know how these
shipping containers are potentially
gonna end up working we're gonna
probably be using these massive farms as
as well as then you describe the you
know even a b2b system like the like the
POS system that the potentially square
won't or visa won't provide your
cannabis shop with dispensary with the
tools you need to process car
transactions things like that well a
whole new POS system can come into place
and say we're specifically made for
cannabis dispensaries we will process
your transactions and then I'm sure that
this is good leading to things like
cannabis and blockchain use or cannabis
and cryptocurrency you will sign it down
without a doubt yeah you know I mean
it's all about spotting these these gaps
in in the space and that's why
grasslands exists I'm good with words
and content yeah ideas branding and I
was just seeing this garbage coming out
of marijuana companies and I'm like I
can help you and that's why grasslands
exists and when what you're talking
about taking it to the next level with
crypto and blockchain and I know some
people who are working on that and it's
brutal they're not seeing major wins or
successes in these early days but
they're they're certainly working on it
and trying to make it happen seem to be
yeah yeah sure
just with the wallet cooked a currency
wallet just go right in get right out
simple as that
don't even need a deal two visas etc so
yeah and looking at blockchain as a
potential solution for the current the
current lack of availability for
traditional banking services you know
the most of these businesses do not have
simple access to banks and and it's such
a shame and and and and shame on the
Federal Reserve for for letting it go
this far it's it's absolutely insane but
right now an average of 60 to 70 percent
of cannabis businesses are banked but
it's all like handshake deals it's all
secret deals and if you talk to a top
provider hey who are you banking what
the chances are they're not going to
tell you because they have an agreement
with that bank and they only tell other
people when it's like the bank says okay
who else is a really reputable business
and they get some recommendations and
the bank takes on ten or a hundred more
cannabis clients so is blockchain that
potential solution I don't know nearly
enough about blockchain to fully
understand that but I know really
intelligent people some of whom used to
work for the Department of Treasury who
think that it is without a doubt the
future the tool and then that that same
process with watching technology can be
leveraged for seeds which will time
bullish will chime into can be leveraged
for the actual lab testing that's being
done so all of that for the security
alright but let's you brought this up we
definitely need to talk about it what
are the monetary gains in terms of taxes
in Colorado um in 2017 or even 2016 and
where did that money go to in terms of
the part of the budget that I got it
that that type of money got allocated to
seems like a really interesting proposal
to tax cannabis and then I'm use it for
education transit yeah the
infrastructure sure yeah it's and it's
legit but at the same time when you look
at in the scope of everything everybody
uses the phrase it's accurate it's a
drop in the bucket you know for example
last year 2017 Colorado sold 1.5 billion
dollars of cannabis and from that I
think the final tax numbers were roughly
around a hundred and fifty million you
know so think about it multiplied by 50
states will end up being five billion
dollars share across the u.s. which is
which is major wait you said one we said
how much of a million 150 yeah 150
million so that's ten yeah it would be 1
billion exactly so it'd be about 550
million times 50 ish so I think that
that's some that could be a major game
changer five billion dollars well but
not really I would argue because you
look at a hundred and fifty a million
for a state Colorado size on one side of
the argument it's kind of mind-blowing
because that revenue that tax revenue
didn't exist five years ago and how it's
there and it's 150 160 million whatever
it is that's outstanding on the flip
side even a small state like Colorado
has an annual operating budget of twenty
nine billion 150 billion to twenty nine
billion is nothing it's inconsequential
but the things that it's going toward
are of consequence so yes we are seeing
the first 40 million go toward the
construction of school projects awesome
and that's that's really was a
cornerstone of amendment 64 when we
voted on that in 2012 huge and and it's
good for them it doesn't cover a lot
it's only 40 million schools are
expensive you know they're fixing tracks
and air-conditioning and heaters and
example classrooms but then what we're
also seeing especially with these local
taxes because the city or the county
they also add a tax on top of what the
state's collecting yeah and we're seeing
small towns like
Edgewater tiny town right up against
Denver and they are funding the majority
of a brand-new nine million dollar Civic
Center home to a Wally Steve's police
station library rec center and a clear
majority of it was funded by cannabis
taxes and their tiny town with three or
four weed shops Pueblo Colorado the
County Commissioners there have a very
pro cannabis business environment and
what you're seeing there is like their
infrastructure has never been in better
shape parks streets sidewalks all being
taken care of and that's cannabis tag
so you're seeing real legit local impact
pueblos they had excess taxes and then
they put it into a scholarship program
and they give scholarships every year
now to kids and they're from cannabis
excise taxes that are unreal so annual
scholarships in Seattle is a degree yeah
yeah but I but it's also important and
to emphasize because I think some people
do come into the conversation and say oh
Colorado must be making a mint and and
it is kind of a lot of money but it's
next to nothing when you put it into
comparison of what that looks like for
an annual operating budget you bring up
a good point if it's thirty billion
dollar annual operating budget and then
it's only 150 million in terms of taxes
from cannabis definitely a drop in the
bucket definitely but at the same time
the local level holy cow yeah I mean a
brand new you know Civic Center with
police station library whoa that's
massive that that was provided by
cannabis taxes and the same thing with
with revamping schools like it's just
amazing to have the industry be so
philanthropic right within its
legislation it's amazing right within
this legislation yes
majority of taxes please go to schools
like let's let's rebuild with this let's
make the impact with this I think they
knew they needed that to pass pass as
well yeah both but both of the besides
of that I mean what would it go to
anyway I can't even envision it going to
anything else besides trying to help out
with society sure and some of its going
to youth education campaigns encouraging
them to wait before consuming or
experimenting and others are also going
toward addiction counseling programs so
it's the state legislators and the
regulators are really trying to funnel
these money this month these monies to a
place where they can help some of the
problems that they think cannabis
legalization is in part responsible for
yeah let's talk about seeds let's talk
about patenting technology and let's
talk about the potential
genetic genetic engineering yet you're
you're already kind of yeah shaken up
about it you know
yeah it's tell us about that it where is
the industry going with seeds and with
patents and with and with genetic
engineering where where is that going we
kind of talked about it earlier with
with mixing together the appropriate
parts of different of THC versus CBD and
then combining those for the one
personalized medicine that's already
kind of some engineering but yeah dive
us into seeds patents etc so we know
that there are scientists out there
right now using tools like CRISPR doing
genetic editing at the cellular level
you know beyond my paygrade but we know
that's happening we know there's a
difference between genetic editing and
genetic modifying but you know I mean
GMOs is something that's very top of
mind and if you google Monsanto cannabis
you'll see all sorts of conspiracy
theories out there but what we've
learned in the last year is that perhaps
these conspiracy theories aren't all
that out there well Monsanto very much
maintains a position that they are not
interested in cannabis at this time one
of my friends and colleagues who's a
great la journalist named Amanda Chicago
Louis wrote a great piece in GQ last
year where she was looking for this kind
of shadowy business she kept hearing
bits and pieces about them and and she
also kept hearing that they were
ultimately patenting individual strains
and individual seeds and she wrote this
kind of murder mystery kind of suspense
thriller story that ran in GQ print and
and she did a wonderful job with it but
also kind of left you wanting more
because in you know inevitably their
private business and she could only find
out so much through her reporting and
through her sources
yeah but she did good work and it very
much opened a lot of people's eyes to
what's happening now and what's the
inevitable future of this because I mean
cannabis is regulated in every state in
part by the state's Department of
Agriculture this is an agricultural
product this is a crop yeah it's a crop
and so I mean it's it's it's derived
from seeds of course a lot of growers
preferring clones but still those clones
those mother's came from seeds yes and
so you know it I think there's no way to
protect this seed from what's already
happened with corn or soy yeah and it's
inevitable and we don't really know
what's happening because it's in the
shadow and it's in the it's in the dark
and we're talking about trademarks and
patents but if it happened with corn
chances are it will happen with cannabis
and it kind of brings up an interesting
thing because it's like marijuana really
wants to be this different industry they
want to you know get they want to avoid
me too because they think they can be
better they want to have more women in
roles of management and ownership
because they think they can be better
and god I wish I really hope that
cannabis can be different exactly what
Iverson yinz more creative opinions
increasing bottom lines by their ego and
opinions for people of color in the
industry on neurodiverse people all this
kind of stuff I love that about that
perspective from from cannabis I think
you'll actually greatly help it but
you're totally right that it's it's kind
of a mystery right now what's going on
in it and that mystery is both has the
potential to impede a lot of creativity
and a lot of the development of
innovation because of greed and um it
might be actually to not be benefit of
the industry to have so many seed
patents and but it might also be to the
benefit of industry to enable genetic
engineering of certain strains and
certain temperatures for certain
pesticides for certain agricultural
purposes may be to the benefit so but we
haven't done any longitudinal tests on
what it would look like to take
genetically modified cannabis for a
period of 50 years right what would that
actually how would it impact the human
similar question that I always ask the
GMO people
as well as have we done a 50-year long
test on what it's it it is like to eat
genetically modified tomatoes every
single day and what actually occurs when
there's genetic modification for for
drought genetic modification for for
insect repellant for all that kind of
stuff I mean it can it can add up to a
lot of different at it's inside of the
genome of the tomato so this is this is
all very interesting where we're going
with seeds and patents and in the
industry it's a necessary conversation
I'm glad you brought it up and I'm glad
you've discussed these issues
surrounding food because obviously you
know we're becoming increasingly aware
and passionate about it and anything
that is a concern to you you know if
you're out there listening and we're
watching it and and if that's a concern
to you when you're shopping at the
grocery store it should also be a
concern to you when you're shopping at
the Cannabis not exactly yeah okay so
let's let's see here what do we got left
we got a couple of the simulation
questions left let's run through them
this has been super solid chatting with
you about all these diverse ideas about
the cannabis industry and the medicinal
benefits the Wellness benefits even like
we were talking about getting away from
opioids and into cannabinoids I think
that is that it's in itself as a huge
spiritual insight for humans to be like
it's an exit drug in that sense all
right so let's start it off hilariously
enough after all these conversations
about the Monsanto
let's ask Ron what he thinks Ron what do
you what are what are you feeling about
the cannabis industry and this forward
movement you feel feel good I hate
waking me today so no I'm looking
forward we
I love it love it so all right we're
just talking about Monsanto we're
talking about patenting talking about
seeds do you think that there is a
global ruling elite inevitably yeah I
don't know that I understand the
specific context that you're asking but
yeah inevitably yeah absolutely I do I
mean are you are you talking about the
select few of the anointed who are
ultimately in charge of what the rest of
us are fed and see and fed in every way
whether we're talking about food or
information yeah the way we're banked
the way were had information actual food
yeah I do you know and I think an
interesting modern representation of
that and you know I'm I know about weed
and journalism and have the stuff I love
talking about but but let me throw
something out there and just see if this
makes any sense you guys here we are in
2018 America and bits and pieces of the
Moller investigation are coming to light
and inevitably we're going to have a lot
more that we're seeing and and and we're
getting this in this this insane insight
into some of these people's lives who
are top advisers to the current
administration and before that were top
advisers to the Ukrainian government or
to the Kremlin and has more and more of
this comes to light and we learn more
about it we recognize you know somebody
at some loser like Paul Manafort has an
amazing amount of influence and money
and scope and sway and I mean that's
kind of amazing because Paul Manafort
it's a total loser and and and yet here
we are it's it's all coming out and he
was responsible for so many things I
mean the money laundering charges are
just the beginning but when you get into
those indictments and you start
recognizing what he and these others are
doing you recognize that these few have
so much say over what we
are ultimately given in some way or the
other and and it's terrifying I mean you
and I have talked about this concept of
of wealth inequality before and and it's
just kind of the same thing it's it's
it's a total sham and and we'd be we'd
have to have our head in the sand if we
were pretending any other way does that
make any sense it does it absolutely
does do you think that one should
endeavor to join the global ruling elite
for potentially the purposes of making
the world a better place trying to bring
good ideas and philosophies into the
meet I do yeah I absolutely do I don't
know how successful they're going to be
you know I it seems when like those
altruist s-- are able to finally reach
that level that they are obstructed to
really create good and to lay out
systems of quality because of you know
they're the minority at that point at
that point in the table you know there's
a lot of evil at that table and a lot of
greed yeah
and I'm one of my favorite recent
readings about the again I think this
was a missing to lib no no actually it
was free free free though I'll make sure
to mention it in the by all aim to
remember but the gentleman that I just
watched a video on he was a very
intelligent intelligent they believe
Italian gentleman but very intelligently
speaking about how the economic system
doesn't have any ethical boundaries for
example if you take a and Brett wines
Weinstein actually mentioned this as
well very smart guy mention that how can
the
for example the microwave industry if
you purchase a microwave each year then
that's actually better for the economy
than if you purchase a microwave only
every ten years so if somebody innovates
and makes a microwave that's better that
last 10 years it's actually not as good
for the economy as if you were if you
were purchasing at every single year
sure so where do we put these like
ethical boundaries within the
conversation of the financial markets to
potentially accelerate the way that we
develop and innovate in ways that are
more ethical so I love that that point
of the conversation is I was so blown
away by that
like of course if you're the elite
you're not going to have in many cases
ethics for making those types of
decisions so sure and if the economy is
growing and thriving at what cost of our
is it growing and thriving for the
everyman you know and that you're
bringing up the ethics of built-in
obsolescence which is a tremendous
frustration that I have an iPhone over
there in my bag and and I hate that it's
a year old and at the time it was
brand-new and it's already super
glitched out and Apple's like yep it's
almost time for baka to buy another
phone exactly and when you're spending a
thousand dollars on an iPhone 7 or 8 or
whatever the hell that is
yeah I mean that's junk that is garbage
and and technology technology should not
be disposable yeah you know and we've
gotten way too far along the way too far
along and and it's dangerous and it
drives me nuts especially you know being
from the lower middle class you know we
I remember buying our first microwave in
fact my mom and I had microwave popcorn
at a friend's house and it was like the
future that you could put this bag in
there and
yes I'm old turning 40 this week 41 this
week and looking good though but well
probably too much microwave popcorn but
you know that was an amazing moment and
we bought a microwave at Sam's Club and
it was a $99 and it lasted us for 15
years exactly exactly yeah so screw the
economy yeah add about four individual
individual good yeah exactly yeah and
collective good both yeah at the same
time okay so that was on that you eat
how about the how about maximizing human
potential how do we do that well I I do
believe that that substances I can
unlock a power in us you know whether
we're talking about cannabis ayahuasca
yeah LSD psilocybin I very much
likewise have experienced that and you
and I have talked about that so you know
the theme of the show is drugs so we
could continue down that path or we
could continue down another path but
what I'm sure you know this general
statistic because isn't it something
like we you only use on average a very
small percentage of our brain you know
on a daily basis what is it seven
percent and the rest is just you know we
fire some pretty consistent neural
networks within our mind every single
day for language and for observing our
environment and seeing different things
and identifying them a certain way
actually like percentage not quite sure
or accurate about it sure but you
definitely write that the mind-altering
substance that's that would potentially
activate new areas of the brain new
neural networks has huge potential for
potentially eradicating ego for
potentially increasing both individual
power but also collective power it's
such beautiful understand
interconnectivity of everything all that
kind of stuff so that's interesting that
you bring that up that that's definitely
it's would you say that that
having a power unlocked by any one of
those mind-altering substances would you
say that at least that's for everyone
one of those things is for everyone now
No
so even then someone that never does any
drugs ever throughout their life that
that's also totally good and that that
can absolutely I think people can lead
to things like ego death through
meditation and stuff like that as well
but I would be very skeptical of
somebody to say that I already have
experienced maximal ego death without
meditation without any mind-altering
substances I'd be skeptical I'd be
interested to know how they did it so
that's what I have to say about that
yeah I mean you can put things into the
body like like substances and you can
also take things out and I did a an
interesting meditation exercise when I
was in India for my first time I found
myself backpacking and I heard that the
the Buddha had attained enlightenment in
this place called boat gaya India yeah
it's right outside of gaya it's a big
ugly city got a boat gaya it's out in
the country and it's beautiful and it's
just monasteries all over the place and
in the Lonely Planet guide book they're
like yeah just show up at some of these
monasteries and talk to the local monk
and see if they'll take you in for two
days for five days did two weeks did it
how long days did you go for I did three
days that's amazing there's no
technology that's no talking that's none
of that exactly
yeah you're just meta to meditating
around the clock and you're also only
drinking water and tea you're only
eating like lentils exactly when my body
I mean I was backpacking through India
so it's not like I was consuming any
substances because if you're you know
you're it's pretty rare to find your
alcohol or cannabis especially then
10-15 years ago but but my body flipped
out still I've probably been eating
mostly vegetarian no alcohol no weed and
two and a half days in my body almost
shut down because I'm that was my first
interaction with meditation and Here I
am on a three-day bender surrounded by
random Europeans and monks
and it was it was a phenomenal reaction
that I very much paid attention to
because uh maybe I wasn't doing it right
you know and maybe that's not the the
reaction that you're looking for your
body to have but it was what happened to
me and it was existential and very very
real and you know certainly unlocked
something in that time that I was there
I would recommend it for everybody and
that's something where it's like oh I
wouldn't recommend cannabis to everybody
but I would recommend a three-day
meditation retreat yeah to everyone you
would yeah that's so interesting that
you like I totally agree with that
I am idea I don't think that I saw I've
been to three ten day-long meditation
retreats where we did the same thing the
boss in the style so I'm aware of well
you're and we're very aware of what
you're discussing and I'm very glad that
you went through that and you call it a
very profound experience for you I think
that it's definitely a part of
maximizing human potential is people
being able to tune in or go
introspective get away from the phone
for a little bit the computer for a
little bit go outside breathe some fresh
air and as you do that close your eyes
and really tune into your heartbeat
tune in to every the impermanence of
your body and then permanence of reality
and just how amazing it is to just be
okay with observing your respiration and
all that good stuff and observing your
thoughts and that will completely change
the way that you interact with people
when somebody potentially pushes some
negative energy on you you will be
slower to react you will spend more time
cognizing and just being aware of the
moment and that negative energy and then
you'll be able to retort with some
positivity and return and stuff so I'm
glad that you bring that up for
maximizing potential I do think that
some form of that without being dogmatic
is really important yeah some form of
mindfulness meditation observing
sensation all that good stuff so like it
changed me for the better yeah and it
like you said it maximized my potential
and that I handled situations a deck a
decade later differently because of that
experience probably exactly exactly I'm
trying to go three times a year to the
10-day meditation retreat
yeah last year - I'll have to trying to
try and do three this year we'll see how
that goes out on the post said maybe you
can come out one of the ones out here
may let me know I'll go to one of the
ones in Colorado alright let's talk
about the most beautiful thing in the
world what do you think that is hmm well
how it's hard to go it's hard not to go
like cliche or trite here cuz it's like
a hoe what a bit what if Alan's past
guests said the most beautiful thing in
the world is oh I was not anticipating
discussing this one you know my mind
initially went to love but I don't know
that's I think that's also maybe a
cop-out so it was especially because
love doesn't only have to be between two
people let's leave with the world and
with existence with just being alive
yeah all that good stuff I would I would
I would say that it kind of takes me
back to this conversation that I had in
college in the tennis courts with my
best friend right after he told me that
he was dating my sister and they later
ended up getting married and having kids
and all this stuff but my friend right
there he was just like he was a full of
philosophy major I'm a journalism major
and you know we're ditching Spanish and
German class respectively and playing
tennis because of course my college and
and he we were just at the net and he's
like well what do you think the meaning
of life is and we were just idiot
19-year olds just like I'm an idiot 40
year-old now a good question to ask a 19
very good question
and so our answers were polar opposites
our and at 19
Troy's answer was procreation Oh and Wow
he didn't even know he was gonna have
kids you know but maybe or maybe he did
but he was just like we're here to
procreate to expand this population and
he said it more a lot more eloquently
and he's like well what do you think it
is and and you know I've never taken a
philosophy class so I hadn't ever gone
that direction but I I did tell him that
I believe that the meaning of life was
to to be a good human and and to enhance
the enhance the lives of those in your
immediate vicinity you know to be good
to people
Zedan so maybe I'll I'll go back to that
answer and but the most beautiful thing
in the world would be you know to live a
life that where you really celebrate
everybody in your immediate circle yes
because I think yes and I'm fortunate
enough to have a really wonderful loving
a family who they they make it easy to
celebrate them yes on a regular basis
and instead of my friends and and the
ones who don't just don't never
penetrate that inner circle but how
incredible is it to surround yourself by
people who are so amazing that it's so
easy to celebrate the badasses that they
are exactly celibacy mm-hmm yeah
celibacy every single day have some
celibacy for yourself being alive the
inner circle that you have of your
family in your community and your
friends and then even abroad so the
other brothers and sisters that we have
across the world to work together I
really like that that's a that's a
that's a funny tennis net conversation
between you guys really it is he's
thinking about procreation being meaning
and you're thinking about being good
people in your immediate vicinity very
very solid and it's not just of course
the people who you know it's the person
at the drive-through window and the
person
satella you know pumping your gas or
whatever it might be Smila j-- yeah I
know just frickin smile and you crazily
change your physiology you'll change
theirs yeah
well during that same period of time
back in college I was dating a woman and
we were going through I think like
McDonald's because we're late for school
and and I was nice you know told the
wise that's the woman how her day was
going and told her to have a great one
and my girlfriend at the time I remember
her she asked me she's like why are you
so nice to like service industry people
and I'm like well I was working with the
Arnold's drive through two years ago
plus why wouldn't you like God what's
the alternative option to be mean or to
be neutral but yeah you're right
especially if you've been in the shoes
that's crazy important I love
fact that I've worked so many dozens of
jobs that are really diverse because I
can get to know the operations of what's
actually going on in the in the world
and the economy in that than those
senses in those positions and those
roles so right yeah yeah okay last - are
we alone in the cosmos definitely not
definitely not I couldn't be more
confident yeah if expand of there for us
oh gosh well I just don't think it's
it's even possible you know it's nothing
that I know about I don't understand you
know the universe the the cosmos I
desperately need didn't they just
announce that Neil deGrasse Tyson is
coming back with a second version of
cosmos yeah yeah and so I've never even
seen his original or or the Carl Sagan
you know yeah yeah so I'm not educated
in this in this realm but I would say
that I am just 100% confident that we
are not alone I don't know why I've just
I got checked and you know the world is
big especially when you zoom out of the
earth and you just see everything
surrounding us and it has nothing to do
with my childhood a penchant for sci-fi
yeah it has everything to do with just
being a realist yeah i knowing there's
no way in hell yeah yeah just how fast
it is yeah it's it's insanely I'm lucky
too we're even to have developed on this
planet there's so many filters that go
into place a dinosaur could easily stick
stuck around if it wasn't for the
asteroid um there's so many filters that
go up and I think we're facing a lot of
filters that are coming may i genetic
engineering nuclear disaster
polarization and dissonance and there's
so many potential disease with
biotechnology nanotech so we who knows
we might not get there who eats up to us
to actually get to the next level of
getting other rocks and harvesting the
power of our star and stuff which other
civilizations might have already done
and might be observing us right and if
the Edward James Olmos remake of
Battlestar Galactica is to be trusted
then it's going to be a hell of a ride
yeah find that other rock exactly yeah
so last question are we in a computer
simulation so when you and I first met
in October in Oakland this was this was
the question that you posed to me under
the pretense of hey next time you're in
the bay come on my show and and I loved
it so much because it it's one of those
questions that that I will be honest I
just I don't even know where to start
but going back to my last answer and it
was a gut answer and one that I didn't
necessarily have a lot to back it up
with I would have a similar gut answer
and I don't think we are
I love reading about it and the people
who do think that we are my god it's so
fascinating and it's so bizarre and then
there are many points there I I hear
those points but no I I don't know I
mean yeah yeah I can't get past the
three well yeah yeah it's very confident
in at least yourself thinking and being
alive and making actions minimally
yourself yeah because who knows if
everything else is actually potentially
real or not and yeah with the vastness
of the cosmos if we actually doubt the
existence of other doubt there's not
other though so we're aware that there
are others then the likelihood that they
have potentially advanced and figured
out fusion or figured out
colonizing their star systems that would
give them enough computational power
especially the quantum computing to
figure out how to synthesize what we are
so it's exciting stuff and what's your
yes or no answer to that question that's
a good question I am I'm figuring it out
I'm continuing to do more Q&A and
research into the field and everything
but I I'm starting to think more and
more that
the likelihood that there is some being
that created things whether it's a
potentially a programmer that is
manipulating the variables of math and
physics for that we live on this rock
that has a certain gravitational pull
that has a certain proximity to a star
that has a certain amount of brightness
that we evolved in this specific way etc
I think that that would be quite frankly
the greatest experiment ever conducted
period to see how all these different
earths evolve around their stars and how
these brains and these flesh vehicles
running around on the planet figure out
are they going to work together are they
going to kill each other
how are they going to do it etc they're
gonna make it to the next rock it's like
such an interesting simulation right
such a yeah so so that's probably like
where my most interesting parts of the
conversation lie but to have a concrete
binary yes-or-no answer can't but yeah
but overall the the entire school of
thought around it's very interesting and
I'm very happy that very happy that that
you remembered that that was the big
question asked enough we've wandered
down so many incredible paths this
conversation we've went across the
cannabis industry in so much detail
covered medicine we've covered wellness
covered the spiritual insight have
covered the regulation the recreational
conversation the medicinal conversation
taxing potential benefits that that has
on the education system on the city
system on the small county level we've
talked about being an exit drug away
from the big ones it's an area and that
keep your eye on that keep your eye on
the industry exploding over the next
decade and and having lots of again
focus on lots of the medicinal benefits
lots of the Wellness benefits not for
everyone of course but still amazing to
think about how it can solve so many
parts of our life like a massive chronic
pain all these things I am just so
fascinated by that I hope it gets out to
more people in the world and it's thanks
to people like you that you're here
we're talking about it so guys thank you
for tuning in it's been great to hear
your answers to all the simulation
questions as well we didn't even you
know we only covered like five of them
but you know we're working on figuring
out how to design the format exactly you
know we usually start with you and what
you're up to and then we get to some of
the simulation questions so we'll play
around with that over time huge thanks
for tuning in again if this was useful
for you make sure to subscribe make sure
to LIKE make sure to comment make sure
to share with other people share about
the great information you learned and
also if this was useful to you become a
patron become a patron get cool access
like talking to our guests get cool
access like exclusive content access to
events ahead of time access to exclusive
videos as well and again huge thanks to
you guys huge thanks to Ricardo thank
you very much it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you for the conversation
thank you it's been a blast and we'll
have Ricardo's links as well in the bio
so check it out follow him thank you
very much everyone